>>> TONIGHT THE JANUARY 6th
SELECTOMMITTEE IS GOING PUBLIC
WITH YET ANOTHER ROUND OF
INTERVIEW TRANSCRIPTS INCLUDING
TESTIMONY BY DONALD TRUMP JR.
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE.
CNN'S SENIOR LEGAL AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT PAULA REID IS
JOINING US RIGHT NOW WITH
DETAILS.
PAULA, CNN IS STILL GOING
THROUGH THIS NEW MATERIAL,
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF PAGES.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU SEEING SO FAR?
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, WOLF.
OUR TEAMS CONTINUE TO MINE THESE
TRANSCRIPTS FOR ANY NEW DETAILS.
LET ME SHARE SOME THINGS THAT
STOOD OUT TO ME.
FIRST LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THESE TEXT MESSAGES FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S SON DONALD
TRUMP JR.
THERE'S ONE TEXT MESSAGE ON
NOVEMBER 5th.
AND IT'S FROM DONALD TRUMP JR.
TO THEN WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
AND IT LAYS OUT A PLAN, A WAY TO
KEEP HIS FATHER IN POWER BY
SUBVERTING THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS.
AND WHAT'S SIGNIFICANT IS THAT
THE PLAN THAT HE SHARES AND
OUTLINES IS ALMOST IDENTICAL TO
THE ONE THAT WAS ADOPTED BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES
IN THE MONTHS THAT FOLLOW.
TRUMP SAID HE WAS NOT THE
ORIGINAL ARCHITECT OF THIS PLAN,
HE CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER WHO SENT
IT TO HIM, BUT HE SAID HE WANTED
TO SHARE THIS SPECIFIC IDEA WITH
MEADOWS BECAUSE HE SAID IT WAS,
QUOTE, THE MOST SOPHISTICATED
AND DETAILED.
AND THAT IT SOUNDED PLAUSIBLE.
NOW, INITIALLY MEADOWS DIDN'T
RESPOND OR ENGAGE IN THIS TEXT
MESSAGE EXCHANGE.
BUT WHEN TRUMP FOLLOWED UP
MEADOWS SAID "MUCH OF THIS HAD
MERIT.
WORKING ON THIS FOR
PENNSYLVANIA, GEORGIA AND NORTH
CAROLINA ALREADY."
SO HERE, WOLF, YOU SEE THE SEEDS
OF THIS EFFORT TO SUBVERT THE
ELECTION, THESE BEING PLANTED
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE VIOLENCE
AT THE CAPITOL.
AND IN THIS EXCHANGE THIS
INVOLVES THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
SON AND HIS CHIEF OF STAFF.
TALK ABOUT INNER CIRCLE.
NOW, ALSO NOTABLE FROM THESE
TRANSCRIPTS, SEVERAL
HIGH-PROFILE POLITICIANS WANTING
TO HELP PUSH THESE FALSE CLAIMS
ABOUT VOTER FRAUD.
FOR EXAMPLE, SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
WE LEARNED ABOUT HIS EFFORTS IN
THE TRANSCRIPT FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER CHRISTINA
BOBB.
SHE TESTIFIED THAT LINDSEY
GRAHAM TOLD, AGAIN, MARK MEADOWS
THAT GRAHAM WOULD BECOME A
CHAMPION OF THE PRESIDENT'S
FRAUD CLAIMS, ALL HE NEEDED WAS,
QUOTE, FIVE DEAD VOTERS.
SHE RECALLS HE HE SAID, "GIVE
ME, YOU KNOW, AN EXAMPLE OF
ILLEGALS VOTING.
JUST GIVE ME A VERY SMALL
SNAPSHOT THAT I CAN TAKE AND
CHAMPION."
AND THIS EXCHANGE, WOLF, CAME
JUST A FEW DAYS BEFORE JANUARY
6th.
BUT IT SHOWS THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
TRYING TO GET SOME HIGH-PROFILE
ALLIES TO AMPLIFY THESE FALSE
CLAIMS.
BUT HERE'S THE KICKER.
HIS LEGAL TEAM ACTUALLY FOLLOWED
UP WITH GRAHAM.
THEY GAVE HIM A MEMO TITLED
"CHAIRMAN GRAHAM DEAD VOTES
MEMO.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION."
BOBB TESTIFIED GRAHAM DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WITH THAT.
GRAHAM'S OFFICE HAS NOT
RESPONDED TO OUR REQUEST FOR
COMMENT.
BUT ONE OF THE BIG THEMES THAT
WE'VE TAKEN AWAY OVER THE PAST
WEEK IN ALL OF THESE
TRANSCRIPTS, WOLF, IS THAT ALL
ROADS GO THROUGH THE FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
A LOT OF THIS QUESTIONABLE
CONDUCT, THESE SCHEMES THAT THEY
WERE HATCHING.
EVERYTHING APPEARING TO GO
THROUGH THE FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF.
>> VERY INTERESTING INDEED.
PAULA, WE'RE ALSO LEARNING FROM
THESE JUST RELEASED TRANSCRIPTS
THAT THE FORMER FIRST LADY,
MELANIA TRUMP, DIDN'T TRUST HER
HUSBAND'S INNER CIRCLE.
TELL US MORE.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT.
HER FORMER AIDE STEPHANIE
GRISHAM TESTIFIED THAT THE FIRST
LADY DIDN'T TRUST THE WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS OR HIS LEGAL TEAM AT THE
TIME, SPECIFICALLY SIDNEY
POWELL, RUDY GIULIANI AND JENNA
ELLIS.
AND THAT IS NOTABLE BECAUSE
AGAIN, MEADOWS IS AT THE CENTER
OF THIS SCHEME TO TRY TO SUBVERT
THE ELECTION AND CERTAINLY THAT
LEGAL TEAM HAS COME UNDER
SIGNIFICANT SCRUTINY IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS.
SO IT IS NOTABLE THAT THE FIRST
LADY EVEN TWO YEARS AGO HAD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE KIND OF
ADVICE HER HUSBAND WAS GETTING.
>> PAULA, I WANT YOU TO STAY
WITH US.
I ALSO WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST ELIE HONIG
AND DEFENSE ATTORNEY SHAN WU.
ELIE, ACCORDING TO THIS NEW
TRANSCRIPT FROM A TRUMP LAWYER,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AS WE
JUST HEARD SAID "JUST GIVE ME
FIVE DEAD VOTERS."
THAT'S A DIRECT QUOTE.
HOW DESPERATE WERE TRUMP'S
ALLIES TO FIND ANYTHING TO BACK
UP THEIR FALSE CLAIMS OF VOTER
FRAUD?
>> WELL, WOLF, ONE THING THAT
JUMPS OUT TO ME FROM THESE
TRANSCRIPTS IS THEY KNEW THEY
HAD NOTHING.
WHETHER IT'S LINDSEY GRAHAM,
DONALD TRUMP JR., THESE
TRANSCRIPTS SHOW US THAT IN THE
HOURS AND DAYS AFTER THE VOTES
WERE ACTUALLY CAST IN NOVEMBER
THEY REALIZED THEY HAD LOST,
THEY REALIZED THEIR ONLY HOPE
WAS TO CONJURE UP THESE CLAIMS
OF VOTER FRAUD, AND THEY JUST
COULDN'T FIND ANY.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS FIND ME FIVE
EXAMPLES AND APPARENTLY WASN'T
EVEN ABLE TO GET ANYTHING ENOUGH
TO SATISFY HIM ON THAT SMALL
ASK.
THE POINT HERE IS THEY KNEW THEY
NEEDED SOME EVIDENCE OF VOTER
FRAUD, THEY HAD ABSOLUTELY NONE,
YET THEY CLAIMED IT ANYWAY.
>> GOOD POINT.
SHAN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
EXCHANGE WE JUST HEARD BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMPER JR AND MARK
MEADOWS, THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF UNDER TRUMP, WITH
TRUMP'S SON SAYING HE FELT THAT
THE MOST SOPHISTICATED PLAN TO
KEEP TRUMP IN POWER, HE SAID
THAT WAS THE MOST SOPHISTICATED
PLAN TO KEEP TRUMP IN POWER?
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT
EXCHANGE?
>> WELL, NOT SURE WHAT ELSE HE'S
REFERRING TO, BUT GIVEN SOME OF
THE THINGS WE'VE HEARD MIGHT BE
SORT OF A LOW BAR OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES PLAUSIBLE AND
SOPHISTICATION.
BUT AS PAULA WAS POINTING OUT,
HIS MESSAGE PRETTY MUCH MIRRORS
WHAT WE KNOW WAS THE LAID-OUT
PLAN,ING THINGS LIKE THE EASTMAN
MILLIMETERO, IN TERMS OF HOW TO
STOP THINGS, HOW TO USE
ALTERNATE SLATES OF ELECTORS.
SO HE'S ON THE MARK THERE.
HE SEES THIS AS A PLAN THAT HAS
SOME DETAIL, THERE IS A PLAN TO
IT, IT'S NOT JUST MAKING UP
THINGS ABOUT THE ITALIAN
SATELLITES, AND MEADOWS IS
AGREEING WITH THAT ASSESSMENT,
THINKING THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY THINK HAS SOME LEGAL LEGS
TO IT, THAT THEY CAN MAKE SOME
HEADWAY WITH.
>> GOOD POINT.
YOU HE KNOW, PAULA, SO LET'S
LOOK AHEAD.
WHAT COMES NEXT FOR THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S CRIMINAL
PROBE OF TRUMP?
>> WELL, THIS IS OF COURSE NOW
BEING LED BY SPECIAL COUNSEL
JACK SMITH.
HE IS EXPECTED TO BE BACK IN THE
UNITED STATES IN THE COMING
DAYS.
HE'S BEEN WORKING ABROAD AFTER A
BICYCLING ACCIDENT AND HE'S
GOING TO HAVE ACCESS TO MOST OF
THIS EVIDENCE THAT HAS BEEN
GATHERED BY THE COMMITTEE.
HE WROTE TO INVESTIGATORS ASKING
THEM TO SHARE ALL THE EVIDENCE
THAT THEY'VE GATHERED.
HIS INVESTIGATORS WILL ALSO HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE TRANSCRIPTS.
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO BE A
GOLD MINE FOR THEM AS THEY
ASSESS WHETHER THEY SHOULD BRING
CHARGES AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR HIS ASSOCIATES
RELATED TO JANUARY 6th.
NOW, THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM TELLS ME THEY ARE NOT
TERRIBLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, THEY BELIEVE THAT
IT'S A VERY HIGH BAR FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO BRING
CHARGES, AND EVEN THOUGH THE
COMMITTEE HAS LAID OUT THEIR
CASE IN WHAT THEY SAY IS A ROAD
MAP FOR BRINGING CHARGES THEY
DON'T THINK THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL LIKELY AGREE.
SO THEY'RE FEELING PRETTY
CONFIDENT.
BUT OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WE
DO EXPECT THAT JACK SMITH AND
HIS INVESTIGATORS WILL PORE OVER
EVERYTHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS GATHERED AND THAT WILL HELP
TO INFORM THEIR ULTIMATE
CHARGING DECISION.
>> YEAH, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
JACK SMITH GETTING A TON OF NEW
INFORMATION.
ELIE, HOW WILL JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT PROSECUTORS BE USING
THIS NEW INFORMATION?
>> WELL, WOLF, LIKE PAULA SAYS,
THIS IS A GOLD MINE OF NEW
INFORMATION.
AND LET'S REMEMBER, WE'VE ONLY
SEEN A FRACTION OF A FRACTION OF
WHAT THE COMMITTEE GOT.
A HANDFUL OF HEARINGS A COUPLE
HOURS EACH.
AND EVEN NOW WE'VE ONLY SEEN
LESS THAN A QUARTER OF THE TOTAL
TRANSCRIPTS.
SO I ASSURE YOU PROSECUTORS ARE
GOING THROUGH THESE TRANSCRIPTS
VERY CAREFULLY, LOOKING FOR
EVIDENCE LIKE WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
BUT DEFENSE LAWYERS OF COURSE
ARE MINING THIS AS WELL.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
INCONSISTENCIES.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
ATTACK THE CREDIBILITY OF
WITNESSES.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN WHAT WITNESSES SAID.
AND THEY'RE LOOKING FOR EVIDENCE
THAT MAY EVEN HELP THEIR CLIENT,
WHETHER IT'S DONALD TRUMP OR
ANYBODY ELSE.
SO THIS IS A REALLY CRUCIAL
FIELD TO PLAY RIGHT NOW.
I GUARANTEE YOU BOTH SIDES ARE
LOOKING AT IT VERY, VERY
CAREFULLY.
>> I'M SURE YOU'RE RIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, SHAN?
HOW MUCH WILL THESE NEW
TRANSCRIPTS BOLSTER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF TRUMP?
>> WOLF, IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BOLSTER IT A LOT BUT IT
CERTAINLY BOLSTERS THEIR
WORKLOAD.
AS ELIE'S SAYING, THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO SCOUR THIS, AS WILL
DEFENSE COUNSEL.
BUT NOW THEY'LL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF THIS TO MAKE SURE
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
THEY'RE FINDING.
THERE MAY BE NEW LEADS THAT THEY
HAVE.
AND FOR DOJ, WHO'S BEEN ASKING
FOR THESE TRANSCRIPTS FOR A LONG
TIME, IT'S A DOUBLE-EDGED SWORD
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE THIS KIND
OF PRESENTATION BEFORE A
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE VS. A
GRAND JURY WHERE YOU CAN REALLY
KIND OF CURATE THE TESTIMONY
SOME, THEY'VE GOT THE GOOD, BAD,
AND THE UGLY IN THERE AND THERE
CERTAINLY COULD BE PIECES OF IT
WHICH MIGHT BE EXCULPATORY OR AT